[Music]
I've decided to keep a journal to set
down all my thoughts and a simple
offense of my day I will keep this diary
for one year and at the end of that time
it will be destroyed
and Karishma son to enlist there was a
family tradition
six months later he was dead in Iraq AHS
lost the sense that the reading of the
Lord praise begun
[Music]
so who are you I'm fine Hill really it's
been a while since we've talked even a
pastor needs bastard did you see the
doctor you need someone to take care of
you but I want you to be happy I know
that nothing can change and I know there
is no hope yes ma'am explosives she was
becoming somewhat I didn't know
opportunistic diseases and our key
martial law you will live to see this
you have no idea what he was thinking no
I'm so frightened these kids that won't
certainty you know don't think follow
they fall prey to extremism it's world
alone no I have not lost my faith do you
think what we did together was a sin
I've seen enough real sent another
difference you didn't tell it please
take a look at your own life before you
criticize others these are frightening
times we have to be patient
well somebody has to do something
in the sole frenzied blood
[Music]
it's not my size
my hands shake as I write these lines
can God forgive us for what we've done
to this world okay know the mind of God
[Music]
you